Pah!
Der kleine Vladik und seine
alleinerziehende Mutter Anna
verliessen
ihre ukrainische Heimatstadt,
als die ersten Bomben fielen -
in Richtung Schweiz,
die Liebsten blieben zurück.
Mama, Papa, Freunde, meine Arbeit.
Der St. Galler Ukraine-Kenner
Marco Ecknauer
holte im Land mehrmals
Schutzsuchende ab.
Die standen in Uniform da,
mit dem Gewehr,
und nahmen Abschied
von den Frauen und Kindern.
Das ist hart.
Anja war im neunten Monat schwanger,
als daheim der Krieg begann.
Das Kind brachte sie
in der Schweiz zur Welt.
Der Vater blieb in der Ukraine.
Ich mache mir grosse Sorgen,
dass wir eines Tages heim gehen,
und ihm das Kind fremd sein wird.
Witalij kam mit Frau und Kindern.
Im Wallis
fand er schnell Arbeit als Hirte,
aber die Zweifel bleiben.
Es ist,
als ob man alle im Stich lässt:
Sie kämpfen dort, und ich bin hier.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
* Kindermusik aus Spielzeug *
Die kleine Daria
war Anjas absolutes Wunschkind.
Jahrelang hatte es mit
der Schwangerschaft nicht geklappt.
Und ausgerechnet dann,
im neunten Monat,
griffen die Russen ihre Stadt an,
Charkiw,
im Nordosten der Ukraine.
Wir waren
in der Nähe der Geburtsklinik,
wo ich hätte gebären sollen,
da waren zerstörte Autos.
Es war noch Rauch zu sehen,
ein Haus war völlig zerstört.
Heruntergerissene Stromleitungen,
das machte Angst.
Diese Bilder haben mich
irgendwie an Tschernobyl erinnert,
alles ausgestorben, niemand mehr da.
* Bedrohliche Klänge *
Anjas Heimatstadt Charkiw
bei Kriegsbeginn vor einem Jahr.
Raketen und Artilleriegeschosse
fallen auf die Stadt.
Hunderttausende
suchen Schutz im Untergrund
oder verlassen
die zweitgrösste Stadt des Landes.
In den ersten Kriegswochen
gibt es Hunderte
verletzte und tote Zivilisten.
Gleichzeitig in Zürich Oerlikon.
Daheim
bei Anjas älterer Schwester Aljona,
ihrem Schweizer Mann Longin
und Tochter Michelle.
Aljona ist diese Tage
ständig in Kontakt
mit ihrer Schwester in Charkiw.
Anja, du und dein Kind,
ihr seid das Wichtigste für mich.
Wir helfen euch.
Ja, wir helfen auch Aljona.
Ja, Sveta will auch kommen
Wir reden noch darüber.
Ach.
* Melancholische Klänge *
Die kleinen frechen Mäuse.
Ich kann dir zeigen ...
Das ist heute.
Das war ein wunderschönes Haus
an einem historischen Platz.
(Mit Akzent) Wie fühlt man sich,
wenn man so ein maternity ...
... ein Geburtshaus sieht. Wie?
Wie fühlt man sich?
Am nächsten Tag: der Abschied.
Longin fährt los in Richtung Polen.
Dort will er
die hochschwangere Anja abholen,
die von der Ostukraine aus
unterwegs ist.
Ich kann mich an den Tag
der Geburt von Michelle erinnern.
Ich stand morgens auf,
glasklares Wetter.
Ich fuhr zum Zollikerberg.
Weisse Schneeberge im Hintergrund.
Einfach eine unglaubliche Stimmung,
so wunderschön, bilderbuchmässig.
Heute Nachmittag dachten wir an Anja
und daran, was sie erleben muss.
Das ist einfach ...
Das ist zum Kotzen.
In einem solchen Moment
wird es schwierig.
Dann ist es gut, wenn man etwas
anpacken und organisieren kann.
* Düstere Klänge *
Drei Tage später.
* Sie flüstern. *
Mit Schwester Anja kamen noch
ihre Katze und vier weiter Frauen.
Fünf Tage war die hochschwangere
Anja insgesamt unterwegs -
mit Auto, Zug und Bus.
Allein an der Grenze
mussten wir 10 Std. warten.
Im Bus war es stickig und heiss.
Das war sehr mühsam.
Will sie etwas gegen Fieber?
* Sie spricht Russisch. *
Das Spital Zollikerberg in Zürich.
Gut zwei Wochen nach ihrer Ankunft
brachte Anja
die kleine Daria zur Welt.
3'720 g schwer.
Es ist noch recht ungewohnt,
nicht mehr allein zu sein.
Am liebsten
würde ich jetzt gleich nach Hause.
Ja, natürlich war es
nicht ihr Wunsch.
Es war nicht geplant,
hier zu gebären.
Tschüss!
Annas Mann und Vater des Kindes,
ein Elektriker, blieb in Charkiw.
Als Mann darf er
die Ukraine nicht verlassen.
Danach wird gefeiert.
First lady.
- Okay, ich bin second lady, ja?
Ich war auch dabei.
- Du warst auch dabei.
Longin ist mit den Frauen,
die alle zusammen russisch sprechen,
in einer ungewohnten Rolle.
Wie macht ihr das?
- Du sagst etwas.
Ich? Ich bin nicht der Vater.
Nein, du bist nicht der Vater,
aber du bist hier als ...
Als was?
- Als ein Mann.
Also, gratuliere. Auf Tascha!
- Danke.
Alles Gute, viel Gesundheit,
und für die Mama auch.
Euch auch ein riesiges Dankeschön
für die Unterstützung,
dass ihr uns aufgenommen habt,
die Hilfe, die Organisation:
ein riesiges Dankeschön.
Bitte, gern geschehen.
Alles, alles Gute.
- Danke.
In den kommenden Monaten werden
ständig mehrere Schutzsuchende
in der Wohnung
von Aljona und Longin leben.
Ein halbes Jahr später, im Oktober,
besuchen wir die Familie Ziegler
in Oerlikon noch einmal.
Die Eltern der beiden Schwestern
sind jetzt auch hier.
Einen Monat zuvor
kamen sie aus der Ukraine.
Die kleine Daria
entwickelt sich prächtig.
Aber das monatelange Zusammenleben
in einer Wohnung
macht sich bemerkbar.
Es wird eng,
insbesondere für die Gastgeber.
Am Anfang
hatten wir für alle eingekauft.
Dann haben wir gemerkt,
dass das nicht gut ankommt.
Sie haben sich bevormundet gefühlt.
Sie haben sich beschwert,
sie müssten immer das essen,
was auf den Tisch komme,
es gebe fixe Zeiten.
Und deshalb haben wir entschieden,
es anders zu machen:
Jeder organisiert sich selbst.
Hier wohnen wir zu dritt:
Ich, Longin und Michelle.
Privatsphäre gab es keine.
Privat - zwischen uns,
aber ich hatte diese Privatsphäre
auch für mich nicht.
Wir hatten keine Zeit für uns.
Zu einer guten Partnerschaft gehört
ab und zu auch Beziehungspflege.
Das ist nicht nur Sex,
das sind auch andere Dinge.
Man möchte auch einfach
mal 1 Std. da sitzen
und schweigend die Gemeinsamkeit
geniessen, das hat einfach gefehlt.
Hier wird ja
nur Russisch gesprochen.
Ich habe keine Gesprächspartner
zu Hause.
Ich fühle mich eher fremd
in meiner eigenen Wohnung,
die ich selber bezahle -
das ist ein sehr seltsames Gefühl.
Longin und Aljona
fanden dann nach langem Suchen
eine Wohnalternative für ihre Gäste.
In einem Zürcher Haus, das im Sommer
2023 abgerissen werden soll,
gab es zwei freie Wohnungen.
Anjas Eltern
hatten von Februar bis September
unter russischer Besatzung gelebt.
Erst nach der Befreiung
durch die ukrainischen Truppen
konnten sie in die Schweiz reisen
und ihr Enkelkind Daria sehen.
Ihren Vater hat das kleine Mädchen
im ersten Lebensjahr
allerdings noch nie gesehen.
In der Ukraine ist er
als Elektriker ein gefragter Mann,
weil Russland immer wieder Elektri-
zitätsinfrastruktur beschiesst.
* Wählton *
(Mann aus Telefon) Hallo.
- Grüss dich. Auf der Arbeit?
Ja, ich arbeite.
- Wie ist es dort?
Wir sind halb erfroren, jetzt gehen
wir kurz zum Elektrizitätswerk.
Wurde das Werk wieder beschossen?
Nein, kein Beschuss,
aber es gab Luftalarm.
Was willst du? Es ist kalt.
Nichts, einfach nur so.
Verzeih, aber hier ist es
unter 10 °C und die Hände frieren.
Verstehe, mach's gut.
Ich küsse dich.
- Ich dich auch.
Es ist -11 °C, aber es gibt
dort derzeit starke Winde,
dann fühlt sich das an wie -30 °C.
Anja fürchtet,
dass zwischen Daria und ihrem Vater
keine richtige Beziehung
entstehen kann.
Mein Mann will,
dass wir hier bleiben.
Aber ich mache mir grosse Sorgen,
dass wir eines Tages heimgehen
und ihm das Kind fremd sein wird.
Sie wächst ja ständig.
Anja möchte nach Hause.
Ja, hier ist alles gut:
ruhig, friedlich.
Wir erhalten staatliche Hilfe,
haben eine Wohnung.
Aber ich möchte heim.
Ich wäre sogar damit einverstanden,
als Freiwillige beim
Wiederaufbau der Stadt zu helfen.
Andere Frauen hier
sagen mir das Gleiche.
Wir wären dafür bereit,
währenddessen die Männer
an der Front kämpfen.
Wir wollen unsere Stadt
von früher zurück.
Es ist eine sehr schöne Stadt.
* Melancholische Klänge *
Wie sieht das Leben in
Annas Heimatstadt Charkiw jetzt aus?
SRF-Radio-Korrespondent David Nauer
war Ende Januar dort.
Er fand die Stadt lebendiger
als noch im Sommer.
Über 1 Mio. Menschen
sollen wieder hier leben.
Tatjana Chomenko ist geblieben.
Auch sie
war zu Kriegsbeginn hochschwanger.
Die Geburt der kleinen Melania
war ein riskantes Unterfangen.
Nach der Geburt musste ich
sechs Tage auf die Intensivstation.
In dieser Zeit habe ich ständig
die Explosionen
und Bombardierungen gehört.
Uns legte man in einen Gang
in eine Ecke,
damit keine Scherben auf mich
und die Kleine fallen konnten.
* Sphärischer Gesang * *
Natalija Denissowa
ist freiwillige Helferin.
Sie trifft viele Menschen
und hört ihre Geschichten.
Es gibt viele schreckliche
Geschichten mit Kindern.
Wenn ich das sagen darf:
Kommt nicht zurück mit Kindern!
Ich verstehe,
dass viele Heimweh haben,
aber es ist noch nicht vorbei.
Es gibt aber
auch sehr viele Menschen,
die sich
mit diesem Umfeld arrangiert haben.
Zu ihnen
gehört das Ehepaar Kotelewez.
Allein mit dem Kind, ohne Mann,
würde ich nie weggehen.
Das ist ein Tabu.
Das Kind muss
mit dem Vater aufwachsen.
Der Kleine vermisst seinen Vater
schnell, wenn er bei der Arbeit ist,
obwohl er daheim arbeitet.
Meine Eltern
wohnen ja in Frankreich.
Sie sagen immer: "Kommt doch zu uns,
wenigstens für einen Monat."
Aber das ist zu lange für uns.
Wir haben uns
das alles gut überlegt.
Vor unerwartetem Raketenbeschuss
bist du nirgends im Land sicher,
egal, ob du in Kiew bist
oder im Westen der Ukraine.
Überall ist es gefährlich.
Hier schiessen sie wenigstens
nicht mit den grossen Raketen,
eher mit den S-300.
* Düstere Klänge *
Nur wenige Stunden später
schlägt wohl genau eine solche
S-300-Rakete in ein Wohnhaus ein.
Eine Frau stirbt,
drei weitere Menschen
werden verletzt.
* Kuhglocken *
Auf der Bettmeralp
wurden letzten Sommer
die Kühe auf Ukrainisch angetrieben.
(Mann) Hopp, hopp, hopp!
* Er spricht ukrainisch. *
Hopp, hopp, hopp!
Witalij Kis kam im April
aus der Ukraine ins Oberwallis,
zusammen mit seiner Frau
und vier Kindern.
Hopp, hopp, hopp!
Ich hatte Angst
um die Familie, um die Kinder,
dass auch bei uns
die Bombardierungen beginnen.
Fast jeden Tag gab es Sirenenalarm.
Die Kinder fürchteten sich.
Fluchtpläne hatten wir nicht,
aber dann erzählte ein Freund,
in der Schweiz könne man sich
einfach registrieren
und eine Wohnung finden.
Wenn du mit den Kindern weggehst,
brauchst du diese Sicherheit,
dass alles gut kommt.
Daheim in der Westukraine
hatte Witalij
einen Bürojob in einer Schneiderei.
Aber das Hirten
sei er sich aus seiner Jugend
in den ukrainischen Karpaten
gewohnt.
Die Erfahrung
zahlt sich hier offenbar aus.
Witalij hat sich gut eingelernt.
Er macht alles perfekt mit.
Wir waren anfangs zu dritt
und ohne ihn ...
Ich wüsste kaum,
wie wir das noch geschafft hätten.
Das war grosses Glück für uns.
Und er bringt auch öfters seine
Söhne und auch seine Tochter mit.
Sie treiben super mit
oder helfen beim Zäune ziehen.
Das ist echt unglaublich,
was die auch mitmachen.
Wie kann dir
eine solche Arbeit nicht gefallen?
Der Bundesrat hat den Schutzstatus S
für Menschen aus der ganzen Ukraine
ausgesprochen.
Die Lage sei unsicher
und es könne überall
Raketenangriffe
auf zivile Ziele geben.
Witalij stammt aus Mukatschewo
im Westen des Landes,
weit weg
von der derzeitigen Front im Osten.
Ich habe mich schwer damit getan,
auszureisen,
v.a. aus ethischen
oder moralischen Gründen.
Du lässt irgendwie alle im Stich.
Sie sind dort und kämpfen
und ich gehe weg.
Sogar hier in der Schweiz,
wenn ich mit Ukrainern rede,
die aus den besonders
vom Krieg betroffenen Gebieten sind,
fühle ich mich ihnen gegenüber
ein wenig schuldig.
Ich bin natürlich auch
vor dem Krieg geflüchtet.
Aber meine Familie war zum Glück
weniger betroffen als andere.
Manchmal denke ich,
das ist nicht richtig.
* Drollige Klänge *
Mit vier von fünf Kindern
kamen Witalij und seine Frau
in die Schweiz.
Der zweitälteste Sohn, 16-jährig,
ist in der Ukraine geblieben und
wohnt bei Witalijs Schwiegermutter.
Wegen einer Sehschwäche
und der fünf Kinder durfte Witalij
die Ukraine verlassen.
Das dürfen Männer sonst nicht.
Die kleineren Buben, Oleksandr
und Artjom
gehen in Naters zur Schule.
Sie sind gut integriert,
schwieriger ist es für den Ältesten.
Andreij lernte in der Ukraine
in einer Musikschule Posaune.
Hier hat er
noch nichts Gleichwertiges gefunden.
Vorerst heisst das:
üben in freier Natur.
Uns hat man gesagt, in der Wohnung
dürfe man bis 22 Uhr üben.
Aber es heisst auch, dass manche
Nachbarn das nicht gern haben
und sie könnten sich beschweren.
(Radiosprecher) Geäussert hat sich
der russische Aussenminister Lawrow
bei einem Besuch in Ägypten.
Lawrow sagte, Russland helfe dem
ukrainischen Volk auf jeden Fall,
sich vom "volks- und geschichts-
feindlichen Regime zu befreien."
Haben Sie gehört, was Lawrow sagt?
Ich habe schon vieles gehört.
Was denn?
Er will eine neue Regierung in Kiew.
Ah! Und wir wollen
eine neue Regierung in Moskau.
Warum soll Lawrow
darüber entscheiden,
wer in der Ukraine regiert?
Die Ukrainer können über ihre
Regierung wohl selber entscheiden.
Und alles, was sie wollen.
Die Russen werden es nie
nach Kiew schaffen, nie.
Wenn schon, dann werden eher wir
bis nach Moskau vorrücken,
aber wir haben das ja nicht nötig.
Wir brauchen nur unser Land,
unseren Staat und unsere Menschen.
* Drollige Klänge *
Putin und seine Freunde -
alle da rein, die ganze Horde.
Sein Vertrag als Hirte
dauert nur bis Ende August.
Die Unsicherheit belastet.
Ja, ich mache mir natürlich Sorgen.
Wenn ich keine Arbeit finde, müssen
wir wieder Sozialhilfe beantragen,
da sehe ich aber keinen Sinn.
Ich will nicht auf Hilfe warten.
Fünf Monate später, Mitte Dezember.
Immer noch auf der Bettmeralp.
Bei der Gemeinde war man sehr zu-
frieden mit dem Mann aus der Ukraine
und gab ihm einen Vertrag
bis Ende 2023.
Zudem hat der Bundesrat den Schutz-
status S bis März 2024 verlängert.
Das beruhigt: Zeit zur Integration.
Wie geht es mit den Kollegen?
Alles gut, ich bin zufrieden.
Sprachlich geht es auch gut -
mit etwas Deutsch und Englisch.
Und ich bringe ihnen
ein wenig Ukrainisch bei.
Es sind aber verschiedene Welten:
Hier Tourismus, daheim Krieg.
Ja, daheim ist Krieg,
viele sind ohne Strom uns Heizung.
Das sagen auch meine Eltern,
wenn ich heim anrufe:
Bis zu 18 Std. ohne Elektrizität.
Gut, können sie daheim
wenigstens mir Holz heizen.
Solche Probleme.
Auch sein Sohn Andreij
ist einen Schritt weitergekommen.
* Guggenmusik spielt
"Believer" von Imagine Dragons *
Ich denke oft an meine Leute
daheim in der Ukraine.
Ich wünsche mir das Beste für sie.
Aber jetzt, wo ich hier bin,
möchte ich auch Neues ausprobieren.
Ich versuche, mich zu integrieren.
Die Guggenmusik
ist aber nur ein Zwischenschritt
in der musikalischen Karriere.
Zurzeit ist Andreij noch in einer
ukrainischen Integrationsklasse
mit Schwerpunkt Deutsch.
(Lehrerin) Welches Hobby hast du?
Musik üben,
spielen und Deutsch lernen.
Sehr gut.
(Gebrochenes Deutsch)
Wir werden zwei Konzerte geben.
Am nächsten Konzert
werde ich nicht spielen,
weil ich in Sion für die erste Probe
im Konservatorium vorspielen werde.
Superschön, gut.
Sehr gut.
- Ja, das ist ja toll.
Das Konservatorium
hier in der Schweiz?
Oder dann zu Hause
in seiner ukrainischen Heimatstadt?
Andreij hat noch die Wahl.
Eine Mitschülerin
hat diese Wahl nicht mehr.
Sofijas Heimatstadt ist inzwischen
fest in russischer Hand:
die Hafenstadt Mariupol.
Es war eine echte Hölle.
Ich habe Leichen gesehen, Blut.
Kennen Sie Horrorfilme?
- Ja.
Genau so war es im realen Leben.
* Düstere Klänge *
Viele lebten in den Kellern.
Wir in einem Abstellraum
für Kinderwagen.
Am Anfang hatte ich grosse Angst.
Aber danach habe ich verstanden,
dass ich mit meinen Liebsten bin
und keine Angst haben darf.
Du musst Wasser und Essen finden.
Dann funktionierst du einfach.
Viele haben es
nicht mehr ausgehalten.
Sie sind trotz Beschuss
auf die Strasse gerannt -
einfach, damit sie wegkommen.
Die Flucht durch das russisch be-
setzte Territorium war sehr schwer.
Die Kontrollen waren sehr streng.
Wir wurden auf der ukrainischen
Seite sehr gut aufgenommen.
Das waren unbeschreibliche
Emotionen, als wir da ankamen.
Mama weinte.
Ich habe versucht,
meine Gefühle zu kontrollieren -
ohne Hysterie.
Aber ich habe mir gedacht:
Das ist unser Sieg.
Das ist unser kleiner Sieg.
Es war, wie nach Hause zu kommen.
* Melancholische Klänge *
In Naters überlegt sich derweil
Andreijs Mutter Jewgenija,
wie es weitergehen soll.
Bis im Frühling
müssen sie eine neue Wohnung finden.
Ein Jahr lang
durften sie hier wohnen,
jetzt brauchen die Besitzer
diese Wohnung selber:
Wieder eine Ungewissheit.
Unten im Tal etwas zu finden,
ist schwierig.
Und sie müssen mit ihrem
Schutzstatus S im Wallis bleiben.
Ich weiss nicht, wo.
Wenn wir hier in Naters bleiben,
werde ich in der Nähe Arbeit suchen.
Wenn wir in ein Bergdorf ziehen,
muss ich dort etwas finden.
Ich möchte nicht wieder umziehen.
Wenn wir
in eine andere Wohnung müssen,
würde ich gerne hier
in dieser Stadt bleiben.
Und in der gleichen Schule:
Schulwechsel mag ich nicht.
Du lebst dich ein
und findest neue Freunde,
dann musst du weg
und verlierst die Freunde wieder.
Ich möchte auch in der Nähe bleiben,
irgendwo, wo man Deutsch spricht.
Familienglück
mit ein paar Unsicherheiten.
Jewgenija und Witalij sagen, solange
ihr Schutzstatus hier gültig sei,
möchten sie auch bleiben.
Jewgenijas Suche nach Arbeit
wurde allerdings jäh unterbrochen.
Wenige Wochen nach unserem letzten
Besuch erlitt sie einen Schlaganfall
und musste
für zwei Wochen ins Spital.
Inzwischen
gehe es ihr wieder besser.
* Sie sprechen Ukrainisch. *
Ein Flüchtlingsbus unter vielen.
Dabei die Bankfachfrau
Anna Stebljanko
aus der zentralukrainischen Stadt
Schytomyr.
Am 10. März 2022 kommen sie
und andere Schutzsuchende
auf dem Zeughausareal in Uster an.
Schweizer, die früher
in der Ukraine gearbeitet hatten,
organisierten die Reise.
Anna, alleinerziehende Mutter,
bringt ihren
vierjährigen Sohn Vladik mit.
Zum Empfang gibt es
Linsensuppe und Rüeblitorte.
Anna entschied sich für die Flucht
nach den ersten Explosionen
in ihrer Stadt.
Ich habe Angst gehabt
um das Leben meines Sohnes.
Du weisst nicht, ob du am
nächsten Tag noch aufwachen wirst,
oder in einem
zerbombten Haus aufwachst.
Daheim blieben ihre Lieben.
Mama, Papa, Freunde, die Arbeit.
Aber wir hoffen, dass am Schluss
das Gute das Böse besiegt,
und wir wieder heimgehen können -
in unser Land,
in die Ukraine.
Dann werden die Geflüchteten
auf ihre Gastfamilien verteilt.
Es ist der 7. April,
ein Monat nach Annas Ankunft.
* Sanfte Klavierklänge *
Sohn Vladik fehle es an nichts,
ihr auch nicht.
Aber an ihren Status
als Schutzbedürftige
kann sie sich nicht gewöhnen.
Es ist nicht angenehm,
Flüchtling zu sein.
Nun ...
Ich bin daran gewöhnt, selber
zu arbeiten - seit ich 18 bin.
Ich habe genügend verdient,
um selber für mich zu sorgen.
Hier fühle ich mich schuldig gegen-
über den Leuten, die mir helfen.
Ich kann ihnen nichts zurückgeben,
weil ich nichts habe.
Darum versuche ich,
mich gut zu benehmen.
Sagen wir es so,
um wenigstens auf der menschlichen
Seite etwas zurückzugeben.
Ich sage immer:
"Wenn es ruhiger wird,
werden meine Türen in der Ukraine
für euch immer offen sein."
"Kommt vorbei und ich werde
euch empfangen, so gut ich kann."
Wie über 80 % aller Schutzsuchenden
mit dem Status S
hat Anna keine Arbeitsstelle, obwohl
sie gesetzlich arbeiten dürfte.
(Anna spricht dem Spielzeug nach.)
Sieben, acht, neun, zehn.
* Kind schreit freudig. *
Ich kann die deutsche Sprache nicht,
mein Sohn ist immer bei mir.
Eine gute Arbeit
kann ich hier nicht finden.
Viele Schutzbedürftige leiden
wegen der Situation in der Heimat.
Was ich sehe, ist furchtbar:
Den Tod von Kindern und Frauen,
unsere Männer in der Armee.
Jeden Tag werden Tote begraben,
schlimm.
* Sanfte Klänge *
Alle zeichnen etwas aus der Ukraine?
Das ist das Thema, ja.
Alle wollen heim,
sie zeichnen alle ihre Häuser.
Sie wollen heim.
Immerhin: Anna hat Aussicht
auf einen Freiwilligenjob.
Bald sollen hier krebskranke Kinder
aus der Ukraine ankommen,
die man regelmässig
ins Spital fahren muss.
Anna wäre eine der Fahrerinnen.
Erster Test mit dem grossen Auto.
(Mann) Tempomat, Cruise Control.
Drehzahl des Motors.
- Mhm.
Die Geschwindigkeit.
Maybe one light is now ...
Dieser ganze Schnickschnack.
Das ist mein Ende.
Cruise control.
Ich steh mal besser auf die Bremse.
Wie lang der Wagen ist.
Das hier ist mein Auto.
Ah, ein Lada.
- Mhm.
Ich muss mich zuerst ...
Wie sagt man?
Daran gewöhnen?
Es ist das erste Mal.
Cool, so ungewohnt.
Mir gefallen die Strassen.
Keine Schlaglöcher,
die man umfahren muss.
* Drollige Klänge *
Mamma mia.
- Police.
Left, here left.
- Left?- Yes.
Right.
- Äh.
Mhm, okay.
Oh, oh, oh.
Ai!
No?
A little bit. It's okay.
Was sagen Sie zu meinen Fahrkünsten?
Fürs erste Mal sehr gut.
- Thank you.
Dann: ein Anruf aus der Ukraine.
Grüss dich. Hörst du mich?
(Aus Telefon)
Ich höre und sehe dich.
Errate mal, wie ich hier
helfen und arbeiten werde?
Erzähl schon.
Ich werde Kinder ins Spital fahren.
Du bist grossartig!
Ich weiss,
dass du gerne heimkommen möchtest.
Wir vermissen dich auch,
aber beeil dich nicht.
Du weisst gar nicht,
wie sehr ich zurück möchte.
Ich will wieder heim - und arbeiten
Warum willst du wegen dieser Arbeit
unbedingt zurück?
Wegen der 250 Euro,
die du hier verdienst?
Bleib dort, um Himmels Willen!
Tschüss.
- Tschüss
* Luftkuss *
Das ist ein Freund,
wir machen zusammen Sport.
Drachenbootfahren. Kennen Sie das?
* Anfeuernde Rufe aus Video *
(Wehmütig) Hmm.
Die Russen
haben uns das Leben gestohlen.
Sie machen unser Schicksal kaputt.
In der Ukraine hat ihr Arbeitgeber
ein Ultimatum gestellt.
Bis im Mai müsse sie ihre Stelle
wieder antreten, sonst sei sie weg.
Anna entscheidet sich
für die Heimreise.
Ihre Gastgeberin
begleitet sie zum Busbahnhof.
Die beste ukrainische Freundin
bleibt in der Schweiz.
Ich hoffe, du hast eine sichere
Fahrt und kommst sicher heim.
Dafür beten wir.
Wenn es nicht geht,
komm wieder zu uns.
Okay?
- Mhm.
Thank you.
Wer wie Anna heimfährt
und den Schutzstatus S abgibt,
bekommt von der Schweiz
eine Rückkehrhilfe von 500 Fr.
pro Erwachsene und 250 Fr. pro Kind.
(Freundin) Have a safe trip!
Die Ukrainer dürfen aber auch
zwischen der Schweiz und
ihrer Heimat hin- und herreisen,
davon profitieren viele -
ein klarer Vorteil
gegenüber den Asylbewerbern.
Jetzt bin ich allein.
Nein, bist du nicht.
Wir kümmern uns um dich.
Right?
- Thank you.
Come on,
maybe we'll see her on the side.
Ein verregneter Januartag 2023
in der ukrainischen Stadt Schytomyr.
* Melancholische Musik *
Ein Leben
zwischen Normalität und Krieg.
Auch für Anna,
die seit einem halben Jahr
mit Vladik bei ihren Eltern wohnt.
* Wählton *
Ich grüsse Sie.
(Stockend) Guete Morge.
- (Lachend) Guten Morgen.
Da.
Wie sieht Ihr Leben jetzt aus?
In unserer Stadt ist es im Vergleich
zu anderen Städten sehr gut.
Ab und zu
gibt es noch Raketenbeschuss,
aber es ist
kein Vergleich mehr zu früher.
Wir haben fast den ganzen Tag Strom
und so weit ist es gut.
Ich selbst
fühle mich aber gestresst,
weil sehr viele unserer Leute
sterben.
* Sanfte, schwermütige Klänge *
Wir haben jeden Tag Beerdigungen.
Es gibt Momente, in denen man lacht,
aber die sind selten.
Wir sind überzeugt,
dass wir gewinnen werden.
Aber die menschlichen Ressourcen
sind irgendwann mal erschöpft.
Pah!
* Dynamische Klänge *
Schutzsuchende
in der Ukraine abholen
und in die Ostschweiz bringen,
das war vor einem Jahr das Ziel
des Unternehmers Marco Ecknauer.
Wo kann man ... Ich muss ...
Die ersten beiden.
(Frau) Ihr Name?
* Er spricht russisch. *
Es gab schon Kinder, die lachten.
Das ist ...
... schön.
Das ist befriedigend.
30 Jahre lang hatte der St. Galler
in der Ukraine
gearbeitet und gelebt.
Darum wurde er
von Schweizer Kirchen gebeten,
die Flüchtlingstransporte
zu begleiten.
Ein knappes Jahr später
wollen wir mit dem Ukraine-Kenner
auf das Jahr
und seinen Einsatz zurückblicken.
* Dynamische Klänge *
Ich holte dreimal Menschen ab.
Die Ersten konnten wir im Kanton
Appenzell Ausserrhoden platzieren.
Es gab mehr Gastfamilien als
Flüchtlinge bzw. Schutzbedürftige.
Wir holten sie
mit zwei Bussen in Lemberg ab.
Wir sind in Appenzell.
Ecknauer fährt
zur Firma KUK Electronic.
Schön.
Hier arbeiten
derzeit 27 Ukrainer/-innen
mit Schutzstatus S.
Firmengründer Hansueli Koster
ist sehr zufrieden.
Er sagt, ein paar
würde er gern für immer behalten,
z.B. Serhii Bakuta,
ein Elektroingenieur
aus der Ostukraine.
Er hat sich bestens eingelebt.
Die ersten zwei Monate
habe ich Deutsch gelernt.
Aber die Sprache brauche ich v.a,
um mit den Kollegen zu reden
und um die Aufträge zu verstehen.
Die Arbeit an sich kenne ich.
Da gibt es keine Fragen.
Danke Serhii, viel Glück.
Alles Gute
und einen friedlichen Himmel.
Iryna Kot lebt auch nach Monaten
noch in einer
Gemeinschaftsunterkunft,
wo sie
ein kleines Zimmer teilen muss.
Aber ihre Ansprüche sind bescheiden.
Sie hat die Hölle von Irpin
durchgemacht.
Wochen
unter russischer Besatzung -
bis ein grüner Korridor aufging.
An dem Tag haben
nicht alle die Flucht geschafft.
Wir mussten draussen warten, aber
wussten nicht, wann der Bus kommt.
Es war sehr kalt,
aber ich habe stundenlang gewartet.
Ich wollte weder essen, noch mich
wärmen. Ich wollte einfach weg.
Entschuldigen Sie ...
Ich habe erschossene Menschen
gesehen, tote Tiere.
Wir hatten Angst,
dass es auch uns treffen könnte.
Drei Wochen
versteckten wir uns im Keller.
Nein, das waren keine guten Zeiten
in meinem Leben.
Ich kenne aber viele,
denen es noch schlimmer ging.
Einige sind tot,
andere haben ihre Liebsten verloren.
In solchen Momenten
ist es dir völlig egal,
ob du noch eine Wohnung
oder Geld hast.
Das ist alles nicht mehr wichtig.
Du denkst ganz anders
über das Leben.
Nicht alle Schutzsuchenden
sind so bescheiden wie Iryna.
Marco Ecknauer nahm
manche als ziemlich fordernd wahr.
Vielleicht taten wir fast zu viel
für die ukrainischen Flüchtlinge.
Sie hatten das Gefühl,
wir müssten noch mehr tun.
Das sei unsere Aufgabe -
auch am Wochenende.
Es gab auch solche Fälle.
Aber ich würde es nochmals tun.
Ich würde nochmals rausfahren
und Leute abholen.
Hier bei der katholischen Kirche
in Teufen
trifft Ecknauer den ukrainischen
Pastor Michail Monachow -
auf Kurzbesuch in der Schweiz.
Der Pastor kümmert sich zu Hause
in Kiew um Schutzsuchende,
v.a. um solche
aus dem Osten des Landes.
In der Ukraine selber
gibt es über 5 Mio. Vertriebene.
Das ist unser Kirchengebäude.
Die Schutzsuchenden
kommen aus Wolnowacha,
Bachmut, Cherson - von überall.
Im Osten herrscht echter Krieg.
Die Menschen, die von dort zu uns
kommen, die haben nichts mehr -
gar nichts.
Früher alles, jetzt nichts mehr.
Die sind jetzt bei uns in Kiew.
Allein unserer Kirche sind
über 1'000 Geflüchtete zugeordnet.
Wir helfen, so gut es geht - mit
Essen, Kleidern und anderen Dingen.
Gerade weil sie helfen, ärgern sie
sich beide auch über Missbräuche.
Ich kenne eine Frau, die als
Schutzsuchende in Deutschland wohnt.
Sie bekommt dort alles:
staatliche Unterstützung,
hat ein halbes Haus.
Alles hat sie.
Ihre eigene Wohnung in Lwiw
vermietet sie gleichzeitig
an Geflüchtete aus der Ostukraine.
Für teures Geld.
Aber ich denke,
das gibt es nicht so oft.
Ich habe auch gehört
von solchen Fällen.
Ich hatte einen Fall,
als mich ein Arzt
aus der Stadt Wil anrief.
Er meinte:
"Marco, ich habe hier vier Ukrainer,
von denen keiner ein Wort Russisch
oder Ukrainisch spricht.
Sie sehen eher aus wie Türken
und einer wie ein Pakistaner.
Sie hatten kürzlich
ukrainische Pässe gekauft.
Die Schweiz hat
für die Ukraine-Krise im Jahr 2023
rund 2 Mrd. Fr. veranschlagt.
Auch Ecknauer und Pastor Michail
helfen weiter.
Die Erinnerungen
an die ersten Rettungsaktionen
spornen bis heute an.
Der Abschied dort war
natürlich auch traurig.
Es flossen Tränen -
auch bei denjenigen,
die zum Helfen hinfuhren,
auch bei mir.
Es ist ...
Wenn die Väter ihre Frauen
und ihre Kinder in den Arm nehmen
und nicht wissen,
ob sie sie wiedersehen ...
Einige standen auch
in Uniform und mit Gewehr dort
und nahmen von ihrer Frau
und den Kindern Abschied.
* Seufzen *
Das ist hart.
* Schwermütige Klavierklänge *
* Chorgesang *
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
L. Pfeiffer, M. Waldner - 2023